>>> THE WAR OVER MASKS IN
FLORIDA SCHOOLS IS STILL RAGING.
PARENTS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
ISSUE ARE NOT BACKING DOWN.
>> THESE DOCTORS THAT SETUP HERE
THAT WERE SNEERING AT US,
LOOKING AT US LIKE WE'RE
SCUMBAGS THEY NEED TO GO BACK TO
[ BLEEP ] MEDICAL SCHOOL.
>> OKAY, RIGHT HERE.
LOOK, RIGHT HERE.
SO AS YOU CAN SEE FISTS ARE NOW
FLYING.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO BULLY HIM
INTO WEARING YOUR MASKS?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
I WANT MY CHILD TO GO TO SCHOOL
FREE AND UNMASKED.
>> SO JUST SIT THERE CIVILLY AND
BEHAVE YOURSELVES OR I'LL HAVE
YOU REMOVED.
I SUGGEST THOSE OF YOU HAVE YOUR
MASKS UNDER YOUR NOSE I'LL HAVE
YOU REMOVED.
>> THIS SCHOOL BOARD IS FOCUSED
ON RAISING YOUR TAXES AND MAKING
SURE OUR KIDS CAN CHANGE THEIR
GENDER.
>> MINE WHO ARE AT HOME RIGHT
NOW SAYING I DON'T WANT TO
WEAR --
>> THERE'S NEW REPORTING A
CHIROPRACTOR SIGNED HUNDREDS OF
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS FOR STUDENTS
WHO WISH TO OPT OUT OF WEARING
MASKS IN SARASOTA COUNTY
SCHOOLS.
HE'S A CHIROPRACTOR NOT A
MEDICAL DOCTOR BUT DIDN'T STOP
PARENTS FROM LINING UP IN HIS
OFFICE TO GETD  HIM TO WRITE AN
EXEMPTION FOR KIDS.
>> Reporter: IT'S JUST AFTER
SUNRISE OUTSIDE THIS
CHIROPRACTIC OFFICE IN FLORIDA
WHEN WE SPOT DAN BUSH WHERE HE'S
JUST ARRIVED IN HIS PICKUP.
HARD TO MISS THE RED WHITE AND
BLUE SPLASH.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THE
EXEMPTION FORMS YOU'RE SIGNING.
>> WE ALREADY MADE A STATEMENT.
>> Reporter: WHY WON'T YOU TALK
TO US ABOUT IT?
ARE YOU EXAMINING EACH AND EVERY
CHILD YOU'RE WRITING EXEMPTION
FORMS FOR SPH.
>> THIS WASN'T ABOUT ME.
THIS WAS ABOUT PARENTS FREEDOMS.
>> Reporter: ARE YOU PUTTING
CHILDRENS LIVES AT RISK BY
SIGNING THESE FORMS?
WHY NOT?
WHY WON'T YOU ANSWER A QUESTION
ABOUT IT?
>> BECAUSE I DON'T NEED TO.
>> Reporter: HOW DO YOU FEEL
ABOUT THEM NOT ACCEPTING YOUR
KB
EXEMPTION FORMS.
WHEN WE ASKED HIS LAWYER EARLIER
ABOUT SPEAKING WITH HIS CLIENT
HE SAID BUSH HAS NO COMMENT.
STILL BUSH HAS BECOME A SORT OF
CHAMPION HERE TO PARENTS LOOKING
FOR A WAY OUT OF THE SCHOOL MASK
MANDATE.
SAYING RECENTLY.
>> I'M NOT AN ANTI-VAX PERSON
BUT I AM A PRO-FREEDOM
PRO-CHOICE PERSON.
>> Reporter: THIS WAS THE SCENE
MOST RECENTLY OUTSIDE HIS
OFFICE, THE TWIN PALMS
CHIROPRACTIC HEALTH CENTER
HUNDREDS OF PARENTS AND CHILDREN
ALL HOPING TO SECURE A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION.
>> I THINK IT'S RIDICULOUS TO
HAVE TO WEAR A MASK FOR EIGHT
HOURS A DAY.
>> Reporter: THIS MOM CAME TO
GET BUSH TO SIGN AN EXEMPTION
FORM FOR HER CHILD, SOMETHING
HE'S NOW DONE HUNDREDS OF TIMES
ACCORDING TO THE SARASOTA SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
>> I THINK IT'S GREAT BECAUSE
MANY DOCTORS ARY FUSING TO SIGN
IT AND THIS IS ONE DOCTOR
VOLUNTEERING HIS TIME WITH NO
PAY TO SIGN ALL THESE FORMS.
>> Reporter: NOT EVERYONE THINKS
IT'S AS GREAT AS SHE DOES.
DO YOU THINK DR. BUSH IS BEING
IRRESPONSIBLE?
>> ABSOLUTELY IRRESPONSIBLE.
>> Reporter: JEWEL SHOALS
STARTED THE GROUP STOP SRQ.
SHE SAID ONE OF HER FRIENDS WAS
HANDED THIS MEDICAL EXEMPTION
FORM FROM DAN BUSH'S OFFICE
WITHOUT EVER MEETING HIM OR
HAVING HIS CHILDREN EVALUATED.
NOTICE IT'S BLANK, NO MEDICAL OR
EVALUATION INFORMATION JUST WHAT
LOOKS LIKE THE CHIROPRACTORS
SIGNATURE AT THE BOTTOM.
>> TO JUST WRITE MASK EXEMPTION
WITHOUT SEEING A CHILD IS JUST
EGREGIOUS.
>> Reporter: DAN BUSH DENIED TO
LOCAL MEDIA HE'S SIGNED FORMS
WITHOUT SEEING PARENTS.
>> I'VE NOT GIVEN EXEMPTIONS TO
ANY PARENT I DO NOT KNOW OF.
>> Reporter: MEANWHILE IN PART
BECAUSE OF HIS ACTIONS THE
SARASOTA SCHOOL DISTRICT TOLD US
THEY'VE UPDATED THE MASK POLICY
AND ONLY EXCEPT MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS FROM MEDICAL DOCTORS.
TO BE CLEAR CHIROPRACTORS ARE
NOT MEDICAL DOCTORS AND THE
DISTRICT WILL NOT ACCEPT THEIR
SIGNED EXEMPTION FORMS.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT ALSO TOLD US
THEY'VE REJECTED ABOUT 650
MEDICAL EXEMPTION FORMS AND THAT
THE MAJORITY OF THE DECLINED
EXEMPTIONS WERE FROM DAN BUSH'S
PRACTICE.
YET THIS PAST WEEKEND DAN BUSH
TOOK PART IN A MASK EXEMPTION
EVALUATION EVENT WHICH MORE THAN
1,200 PEOPLE REPORTEDLY
ATTENDED.
THE FLIER NOTED MEDICAL RECORDS
HELPFUL BUT NOT MANDATORY.
>> RANDY JOINDSS US NOW.
I'M SURE YOU HAD A LOT OF
QUESTIONS FOR THAT CHIROPRACTOR.
>> YEAH, ANDERSON.
I CERTAINLY DID.
I WANTED TO SIT DOWN WITH HIM
FOR A REAL INTERVIEW.
I WANTED TO ASK HIM WHY HE'S
SIGNING THESE MEDICAL EXEMPTION
FORMS, WHAT HIS EVALUATION
PROCESS IS FOR THESE STUDENTS,
WHY HE THINKS HE'S QUALIFIED TO
SIGN THESE EXEMPTION FORMS.
BUT INSTEAD OF THIS THOUGHTFUL
INTERVIEW WHICH I WAS LOOKING
FOR, WE HAD TO TRY TO CATCH WITH
HIM IN THE BACK ALLEY OF HIS
OFFICE, WHICH I DID.
WE SPOKE WITH ONE WOMAN WHO
DIDN'T WANT TO GO ON CAMERA BUT
SHE TOLD US SHE AND HER SON
WAITED FOR FOUR HOURS FOR DAN
BUSH IN AUGUST TO TRY TO GET AN
EXEMPTION FORM, AND IN JUST TWO
MINUTES THEY GOT IT.
SHE SAID HE BARELY EVALUATED HER
SON.
LOOK HIM OVER, DIDN'T ASK FOR
ANY MEDICAL HISTORY, DIDN'T
CHECK FOR ANY VITAL SIGNS OR
ANYTHING BUT FILLED OUT THE FORM
AND SHE WALKED AWAY WITH IT IN
JUST A COUPL